Last night, I managed to take some time off...
...to go to the restaurant, General Lafayette, with some friends.
I had a Parisian dish called steak tartare.
That is raw beef, prepared with a mix of ingredients...
...including: ketchup, egg yolk, onions, Worcester Sauce, etc.
In the restaurant, they even add nut chips and blue cheese crumbs. Yummy!
Well, that is if you like raw meat, of course.
I looked everywhere and could not find the origin of steak tartare for sure,...
...but one thing seems to be certain: originally, it was meant to be horse meat.
My friends told me that in the US,...
...restaurants would be reluctant to serve raw meat because of liabilities.